and trouble too for millions of college
seniors entering a job market that's
been devastated by this pandemic many
are competing with laid off workers and
some are seeing their plans derailed by
the coronavirus a recent poll found 75%
of college students with jobs have had
their work cancelled moved remote or
delayed in our series on the financial
fallout from the virus Meg Oliver spoke
to several college seniors about their
future in this difficult time college
senior Nia Spencer dreams of becoming a
personal chef she was well on her way at
culinary school with a paid mentorship
upon graduating in June then the corona
virus hit she moved home and now her
mentorship is in limbo how are you
feeling Nia is not alone college seniors
around the country are finding
internship offers revoked and job offers
disintegrating yes very much
I had to move back to Utah within two
days rosario Bibiana was in the middle
of her dream paid internship at a
Smithsonian Museum in New York City when
it came to an abrupt end maybe like two
more weeks
so I was really money but the University
of Utah where Rosario is a senior helped
her secure a job as a Kovac 19
communication specialist in a new
program it created my resilience being
proven over and over again this is the
worst case scenario for the class of
2020 I believe it is yes Kati Abby is an
assistant dean at the University of Utah
with jobs and internships evaporating
the university started offering
financial incentives for students to
stay in a 10 graduate school they also
helped create a paid internship program
for students
like Rosario what's your advice to a
graduating senior when they're looking
at such a bleep job market I want to
reassure them that they need to continue
to try and find opportunities and we're
going to help them the best that we can
to do so but it's really important for
students to be open to new ideas new
ideas like remote internships in a
recent survey from the National
Association of Colleges and employers
29% of employers reported they will now
conduct internship programs virtually
this is a great time to really focus on
your skills and improve your abilities
Nick's Borromeo is a senior at the
University of Maryland College Park he
had been interviewing for a finance job
in California when the company froze
hiring he currently has a virtual
internship he's hoping he can extend I'm
fortunate to have that opportunity
because I'm still learning even though
I'm I'm staying at home but a remote
internship is not an option for Nia
Spencer she's been working hard since
returning home from school sharing her
culinary creations on Instagram and
selling food to her community she's a
great attitude now here at Montclair
State University in New Jersey they're
advising graduates to get comfortable
and start practicing virtual interviews
some tips that will sound familiar good
lighting goes a long way find a simple
backdrop and Anthony of course don't
forget to smile yeah I really like Mia's
confidence Meg you need that right now
but as one grant is that one graduate
told you their resilience is being
tested over and over again and their
most looks like they're coming through
thanks Meg